good afternoon everyone how
are you how was your lunch
good it's good to be back in the house of god
to look at his word this is supposed to be a
question and answer session but before we
get into questions and answers let me just
lay the foundation what was the title
or the topic of this past week's lesson
end time deceptions all right
go to matthew 24. matthew 24 we'll read
verse 3 and verse 4. matthew 24 3 and 4.
before we read that let's pray our father in
heaven as we study a word as we're prepared
to answer questions let the spirit of truth be
with us i pray to guide our minds into truth give
us a willingness to obey what we learn in jesus
name amen all right you have matthew 24 verse 3
are you not answering do you have him
read verse 3 for me what's he saying
and as he said on the mount of olives his
disciples came unto him privately saying
when shall these things be and what shall be thee
of the and of the end of the world they won't know
two things or three what shall when shalt these
things be what shall be the sign of thy coming and
of the end of the world what does jesus say
in verse four does he tell them the first sign
take heed that no man deceive you
jesus says do not allow anyone to deceive
you go to second thessalonians chapter
two we'll read verses one two and three
second thessalonians two one two three
yes 2nd thessalonians 2 reading from verse 1.
all right someone has found it anybody else
second thessalonians chapter
two reading from verse one
do you have that now read for me what does he say
now we beseech you brethren by the jesus christ
and by our gathering together unto him that ye
be not soon shaken in mind come on keep reading
or be troubled neither by nor by no by as from
us as that the day of the lord is at next verse
let no man deceive you by any means okay stop
right there let no man deceive you by any means
that's a comprehensive call resist temptation
watch for it let no man deceive you by any means
jesus says take heed others be alert be
on your peace and cues be on your toes
do not let people deceive you and
paul said let no man deceive you by
any means now having that warning from
paul and jesus let's go to revelation 12
and read verse nine and this is as a prelude to
the answering of questions revelation 12 verse 9.
the last book of the bible chapter 12
the first chapter of the second half of revelation
chapter 12 verse 9 when you find it let me know
all right we together and the great dragon
was cast out that all serpent called the
and which deceiveth the he was cast out into the
earth and his angels were cast out with him now
in revelation 12 9 the devil has four
names identify them dragon serpent devil
now each one teaches us something different
about the devil now we see this repeated in
revelation 20 let's go to verses one and two
we see those names revelation 20 1 and 2.
are you there come on read nice and clear what
does it say and i saw an angel come down from
heaven having the key of the bottle of spit and a
great chain in his head come on reed and he laid
hold dragon that all which is the and and bound
himmer okay now we have the four names repeated
devil dragon satan serpent now let's try to
identify what each name is supposed to suggest
okay all right let us go to malik not malachi
zechariah chapter three we'll read from verse one
zechariah three reading from verse one
zechariah should find that easily just
get matthew and get matthew and zechariah
i mean malachi and zechariah very good thank you
do you have zechariah now all right chapter three
read from verse one are you ready nice and clear
what does it say and he showed me joshua the
high priest standing before the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right hand too ah
now we have a clue as to what satan means
satan resists he is an accuser that's what he does
he when we come to christ forgive my sins the lord
forgives us he comes and he tries to accuse us of
forgiven sins and when many times he's successful
because people don't believe they're forgiven and
it continues to repress them the lord has forgiven
we don't believe it because many people want
to feel forgiven when the bible does not call
upon us to feel forgiven it just calls upon us to
accept what the bible says and so that satan is an
accuser now let's go to first peter chapter five
we'll read verse eight to see what the devil is
first peter chapter 5 we'll read verse 8.
read with me be sober be vigilant because your
adversary the devil as a roaring lion walketh
varsity in whom he may devour so the devil is
an adversary so satan is an accuser the devil
is an adversary now we know what the serpent is
what is he a deceiver the dragon is a destroyer
you read revelation 12 17 and the dragon was
wrath to the woman i went to make war with
the remnant of her seed the dragon is a destroyer
satan is an accuser the devil is an adversary and
the serpent is a deceiver now keeping these four
things in mind let me quiz you devil means what
satan means one dragon means what
and serpent means what deceiver now listen
to christ take heed that no man accuse you
take heed that no man is your adversary no he says
take heed that no man because of the four things
destroyer accuser adversary and deceiver the one
that is most effective is deceiver so paul says
let no man deceive you by any means not let no
man accuse you let no man deceive you and so what
i'm trying to stress before trying to answer some
questions deception is the devil's primary weapon
you ask the question now then how do i
resist deception how do i immunize myself
against the virus of deception and
there is only one way and that is this
taken as it reads
what did i just say you must take it as it reads
unless where it is clearly symbolic-like and i
stood upon the sand of the sea and saw a beast
rise up out of the sea having seven heads and ten
horns revelation 13 1 that's clearly symbolic but
most of the bible is literal take it as it reads
obey it and you will have a protection against
deception that the devil will not be over able
to overcome and so before answering some questions
i wanted to place this before you there's a second
thing i want to place before you before we take
questions let's go to mark 12. mark chapter 12.
we'll read from verse 28 mark 12
reading from verse 28. mark 12.
you have that all right read with me and one of
the scribes came and having heard them reasoning
together and perceiving that he answered them well
asked him which is the first commandment of all
stop what do you understand by which is the first
commandment does it mean first in numerical order
what do you think is meant by first
commandment the one the more important
jesus answered him and said the first of all the
commandment is hear o israel the lord our god is
one lord and thou shalt love the lord thy god
with all thy heart and with all thy soul with
all thy mind with all thy strength this is the
first commandment and the second is like namely
this thou shall love thy nearby as thyself now the
bible teaches that one is higher than the other
clearly go to matthew 10 verse 3 verse 37 and see
how the bible teaches us which is higher than the
other now both are important do not misunderstand
me but one is higher than the other and we'll see
that in matthew 10 37 have you found that just
before mark is matthew matthew 10 37 read with
me he that loveth father a mother more than me
is not worthy of me come on and he that loveth
oh more than is not worthy of me now where
do we find mother and father in the law
commandment 5. okay now the first
table of the law is one to four
the next table 5 to 10. jesus says
don't love table two more than table one
he didn't say hate table two he said
don't love it more than table one
don't love your parents more than you love god so
one is higher than the other but both are divine
ella white was taken in vision and she was shown
the ten commandments in the ark the heavenly arc
she said all of them had a light all of them had
a light around them the first four their light
was brighter than the next six and the fourth
commandment had a halo around it of all it was
the only commandment with the halo all around
it that tells you something now i'm saying now
there's another verse it doesn't come to mind
it's go to matthew 23 you'll find it for me
where jesus says you have omitted
the weightier matters of the law
find that for me want you scribes and parentheses
you pay tithe of anus cumin but you've waited
what what verse is that read it for me
now warned to you items and pharisees
the hypocrites aha now listen
carefully epay ties of aha
have omitted the weightier matters of
the law judgment mercy now okay stop
clearly christ is saying some spiritual
responsibilities are more important than others
christ said i desire mercy and not sacrifice
are you with me hath the lord as great delight
in burnt offerings and sacrifices as in obeying
the voice of the lord behold to obey is better
than sacrifice or understand some things are more
important and precious to god than others now i am
saying that to say this when you come to ask bible
questions there are some topics more important
are you with me wherever i have a bible a question
answer session people want to know whom did cain
marry are you following me can you tell
me what that has to do with salvation
now i'm not trying to tell you what to ask follow
me clearly but there comes you must reach a place
of spiritual maturity where some things are you
with me that's for two-year-olds not for me who
the kid mary i'm a 40-year-old man what do you
mean holy can't marry tell me about the 2400
2300 day prophecy tell me about daniel 13. tell me
about rep then matthew 24 not who did cain marry
even though it's a legitimate
question so i'm saying to you
as you ask questions ask yourself of what
spiritual value is this how will people benefit
if someone asks how tall was adam i don't know
15 feet 14 feet okay 15 feet one inch okay okay
don't call the police i thought it was 15. so
consider that as you ask your quest try to ask
questions that really have to do with
salvation otherwise says not even 144 000
is a topic that is so worthy of all the
discussion and the arguments that we get into okay
i suppose i've had half an hour i took 15 to go
through all of that i hope you learned something